what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be reacting to kevin
samuels savage moments before i start do
not forget to subscribe to the channel
and ring the notification
bell you guys already know i'm trying to
get to 20 000 subscribers
so each and every one of you helps a lot
okay
children can come out of whatever or i
do i can be 70 years old
as long as i'm not shooting blanks i can
make babies you can't
the reason why um i became a bottoming
technician is because
there's something called a paramedical
insurance examiner let's get the [ __ ]
out of my phone [ __ ]
i don't get the phone go take blood boy
came and you ain't woke a job where
people quiet in the background
damn damn
[Music]
have you watched one of my videos
a three hour video from front to back
back the whole situation
no kevin three hours is too long i'm
sorry
i'm just gonna stop drinking that girl
you're not paying attention when he was
what
talk to him i'm you watch one of my
videos have you watched a full video of
mine from front to back one of the one
of my live streams i just thought
i just saw one video um was it the whole
i think it was a whole video of some
girl we used
when you were he was ranking her he
asked her what her what
what her ask her what she ranked herself
i have a full three-hour show that i do
and you watched a seven minute clip
i challenge you and your friend to go
back to my channel and watch the full
30 minute ah now see i'm not going to do
this
see here's the problem but but but you
haven't even
you haven't even responded to what i
said you haven't even watched the full
video
of where the excerpt was coming from and
then but your friend has the nerve to
make a judgment
that women have no problem judging me on
partial information
please and you and you women are acting
just like so many women who get upset
you have little
to no information you're not willing to
do the work to ask you certain questions
and what you're responding to i'm
responding back to it so
you're you're referring to past videos
by referring to things that you're
telling me now
but you don't even let me you don't even
let other people talk you're asking me
how old i am you're generalizing women
no yeah he should have kicked her off a
while ago okay
why why because
i don't get i'm stingy i'm stingy with
the with the pups
excuse me i'm stingy with it i do not
give it up easily were you married to
your were you married to your daughter's
your baby mama right never been married
no but i just okay
hold on let me let's talk about this
though see
um i find it funny that
women like yourself baby mamas all of a
sudden want to get stingy with the puss
after you gave your womb up before a
ring
damn but then you want the high value
man
to put a ring on it before he gets it
what am i supposed to
give it away you got damn right you
already did
the thing see that's what i mean
man you're a used vehicle wanting brand
new 2021 prices
you can laugh all you want to but you
just said six months
you're not even exclusive you're talking
about he's marriage minded what do you
think he's inserting his penis in his
hand
no that's the thing he could be in
certain somewhere else exactly because
here's the thing men with options don't
play these games
damn okay hello
all right you were saying do i want to
hear about your original plan
right okay no and i will tell you why
oh no you're not doing it you're doing
what you have to do to survive
and live okay okay
so your original plan it doesn't matter
it ca it does if it can change my
situation
go ahead since you know i do
no know nobody ever said that anyway i
mean i don't
i mean go ahead dude everybody's acting
like that the reason why
um i became a photography technician is
because
there's something called the paramedical
insurance examiner
i'm not sure if you heard about about
that doesn't matter go ahead
i don't i don't have to know you all
right all right look at it man don't be
a [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] off my phone [ __ ] i don't
get the phone go take blood boy
came you ain't woke a job where people
quiet in the background
[Music]
well kevin uh mr samuel it seems i'm
just i have a question did you date 30
year old women
because you mentioned on the last show
and that is a question why
yeah i mean if you're doing it why would
you say you're because okay first off
let's how about
okay you want to answer that question
it's a double standard
just like you can stay at home while i
gotta go work
if i was at home and you work people
would look at me a certain way
this is a double standard that's been
with us since time immemorial
children can come out of whatever i do i
can be 70 years old and as long as i'm
not shooting blanks
i can make babies you can't hey i don't
care what you look like
so i don't really say no no i don't care
what you look like
before a woman's gonna sign off and
become your missus they're gonna check
their pockets
so don't so so if you honestly think
okay
here's the thing uh and i don't know
your first name so what is it
walter walter if you would if you were
to wake up tomorrow be
broke how long you think your wife would
stay until i die
okay hope hope that never happens to you
hope you never
but that would be the first woman in
here but i went to the first woman
but where's your wife sleep was she
talking to me no she just walked up to i
woke up i'm not going i'm not going to
inject any difficulty into your marriage
i got gray in my beard and gray on my
head and uh what you saying just
knocking pulling anything i've ever
experienced in my living life
you're a very good communicator i know
thank you very much
i said money is more than nice it is
required if you expect to have a woman
especially a woman of quality damn
thanks to find you still having to find
quality everyone's
all right see i'm not gonna go back and
forth with this
again see this is part of the problem
young man this is a man who's sitting up
in the house
with a wife and gonna sit there and tell
you money's nice but you know
his dude is honestly trying to say miss
walter
your husband just said if he lost all
his money you'd be living right on the
corner with
yes ma'am you and your older age because
i'm assuming i love this same age
this man is basically said if he lost it
all you'd be happy to be going
living in that box with him until he
said until he died
that's what he said until he died
that's the energy you're getting because
you're a guy that said you don't think
you should have to approach women
they should give you choosing signals
where would you rank yourself
on a scale from one to ten how tall are
you five ten five ten how much do you
weigh
so you're a fat [ __ ]
you think of 5 foot 10 almost 300 pound
dude how much money you make
like 482 week four so you make 400 every
two weeks so you make 800 a month
you make uh less than ten thousand
dollars
but how many 20 year olds was healthy
dude i was a 20 year old and i was
making far more money than that in the
80s or minimum wage was 335 an hour so i
need to hear it
how long you got a big dick
i mean it's above average i ain't no ron
james no no no no no i actually
had a big dick i just said it was above
average i don't know what that is really
you know if you got a big dick or not
stop the [ __ ] every dude know what
not he got a big dick i know i got a big
dick you don't know
i mean you don't have a big dick that's
the point you don't have a big dick
you don't have a big wallet you're a bit
you're a fat dude
and you got a lot of nerve thinking you
should get choosing signals at five foot
10 and 300 pounds
making less than a thousand dollars a
month at 20 years old
damn damn we should approach you what
they get they don't even get a big dick
[Music]
damn he's just as mean to men as he is
to woman
let me know in the comments what your
favorite kevin samuels moment is
tag the video so i can react to it do
not forget to subscribe i will talk to
you guys
next time